money ain't everything as this button is
but it's not but it's not but it is but
it's not okay coming from the
billionaire herself okay by now we all
know that kylie jenner is a billionaire
but she's shaking up her empire
potentially growing even richer thanks
to a major business move that she just
made I'm Kylie Jenner and I am the
founder of Kylie cosmetics on Monday
Kylie and cosmetics brand Cody announced
they have entered into a long-term
partnership they will be developing
Kylie's beauty business which means a
whole lot more Kylie cosmetics but get
this as part of the deal Cody acquired
51% of Kylie's brands and all for a
whopping price of six hundred million
dollars this also means kylie is no
longer the majority shareholder of her
own company though according to the
press release Kylie will still continue
to lead all creative efforts in terms of
product and communication initiatives
I've put so much love into everything
that I make and I make sure everything
is perfect of course last year Forbes
dubbed Kylie the youngest self-made
billionaire
thanks to her beauty Empire starting a
company on my own and it being so big
from the beginning there's not a lot of
room for mistakes and Kylie recently
sort of opened up about her billionaire
status on The Ellen Show and how her
sisters feel about it do they really
make fun of you do they give you a hard
time it's only when we I don't know when
we're like in a group chat talking about
like we should go on a trip and that
everyone's like Kylie question mark
you're gonna pay for it all right just
stuff like that I would but they just
joke with me just sister snakes are like
proud of me for sure and do they but do
they really do they expect you to pay
for all the stuff no they don't really
know just my stuff
what you paid for my stuff and though
she jokes her family gives her a hard
time
they have been super supportive she made
her own money for over a decade she put
it in the bank
she saved every nickel and then when she
decided she really you know decided on
what she wanted to do she spent her
money on a venture that could have gone
south or north and it did really well I
don't care who you are how you you know
but when you don't get it from someone
else that self-made so it's not like
that was handed to her she figured that
all out I mean we all know all right
guys that is it for today for all the
latest on Kylie and her money and the
rest of the Kardashians stick with all
things et until next time I'm Katie
Krause and bye for now
[Music]